all right welcome I need to go offline
welcome back to what this game oh hello
ladies they keep following me it's
somewhere I honestly I hunt planing so
long as I don't remember where I left
off oh [ __ ]
don't copy me this is probably not where
I left off I accidentally deleted some
of the files fraps ticks or whatever I
do that all the time with not the fire
yeah friggin talk yeah yeah
that is how bro that is pretty girl sexy
holy count when I'm doing this head
wake up wake up don't just look oh oh
wow oh that is awesome
I mean
nothing in the car stop oh my god
oh there we go 360 yeah I don't even
remember what I done this game it's been
so long I missed you guys
yeah what um yeah I guess I just should
play oh dude
smells delicious oh nice job bro what
was i doing down here
what anyway freaking them nisha job is
enough this way apparently Oh
oh man that reminds me it was so funny
when I played with Prague Lee I I didn't
remember I wash it afterwards a lot of
funny moments in it I'm sorry
this is not
a very good place because whatever but
I'm gonna continue from here anyway
I don't have the safe files and whatnot
and I can't go back and derpa dirt what
else else yeah me too but my pants are
always crapped what they could be they
wanted it to oh dude nope you guys take
care of that
it's like it's night
not working too well for me this come on
oh [ __ ] I hate the runners haha I forgot
hide that again though come on come on I
don't want to hug you Jesus Christ hug
someone else thank you
stop copying my lines that's totally my
line to say that wasn't you was it you
Rodriguez where are you that was
Rodriguez oh you oh wait don't shoot
creepy zombies if you whoa what the oh
yeah they're all sort of creepy [ __ ] I
was like what the hell is he talking
about oh [ __ ] what wait am i awake get
me a gun there we go this gun works
pretty good at though [ __ ] creepy
zombies alright
creepy zombie let's go let's go oh go
bro
go bro oh snow
hello moe
but oh that was an ethnic group I'm miss
whipping oh my god it's up with this
what then
[ __ ] event which [ __ ] way which
[ __ ] Oh ma'am I really am mmmmmm I mean
come on no I want to get out of this
[ __ ] can I lift it or something I could
I'm a JD ash oh I feel good that sounds
almost too good what oh yeah just relax
over here guys don't mind me i doing all
the [ __ ] work that's all specially
you Rodriguez Oh what oh god I have not
miss ments
hello okay we're good
hey Nene
oh what the
what the what no no no no
that's the same room I got a shake I
know I'm walking backwards oh well whoa
whoa whoa no no no no no no no no no no
no no no that is so creepy I get [ __ ]
goosebumps from that oh my god okay
let's go
agree yes though we get we get we're you
good no problem no problem
never had a problem in life before ah
problem uh problems everywhere ah okay
keen this I can solve problems storage
ah ah
problem problem problem problem huh what
what what was that why am i making up in
boxes who said I was making out for them
Rodriguez what okay let's go
I don't ah [ __ ]
yes and I'm not a flashlight [ __ ]
great ah come on
Oh
that brave ever ever ever asks oh what's
it thought you guys were dead all right
let's go then wait nope hmm you think
you're deaf think you can damn okay this
time Rodriguez all right [ __ ] Susie
me first
okay oh don't scare me you [ __ ]
[ __ ]
Jesus penis pick it up there we go
Jesus okay
maybe they're scared of flares
they're first uh-oh what the [ __ ]
where
that bluey
holy [ __ ] I miss bluey oh crap they're
dying yeah okay I'm bringing blue view
though [ __ ] you guys
bluh bluh
whoa reload [ __ ] back
yeah
like a [ __ ] am I going I'm so [ __ ]
lost Louie show me the way
weeks oh sweet Thanks
oh my god no no wait we're good we're
good
[ __ ] epilepsy flashlights Jesus Christ
stop doing that it's so annoying
whoa whoa you better [ __ ] night
ah there's two of them bluie you can do
it thank you
[ __ ] three
what was it called creepy zombies such a
stupid [ __ ] name
ah just cry some corner me fair fine
he's bound me isn't it it's good
go [ __ ] penis ah
they can blow it right in this [ __ ] I
mean if it shits out of this face and
that's this [ __ ] it's just saying
okay let's go on huh [ __ ] chop
[ __ ] shut [ __ ] shut [ __ ] come
on come on shoot him in his mouth
okay he doesn't like that it's bluey
ah
gay [ __ ] music is gay
are we out of here soon [ __ ] singing
forever
Jesus Christ is look at this maze
meg I'm not talking about hockey
we get I guess
I did that
yeah he'll fax of course because I
weighed over those [ __ ] slowpokes
who all looks exactly the same but I
know your Rodriguez aren't you you
little [ __ ]
whoa sarin or gas yeah I want that too I
want to see you savings what
that's [ __ ] late can't screen too
much I'm gonna try at least what are you
doing
just open the [ __ ] door it's the
oldest game are you like blowing stuff
them
okay thanks
already did you stupid [ __ ] we lost a
guy oh there he is
all right you do it
are you [ __ ] kidding me you [ __ ]
douche bag oh my god yeah thank you
I don't spend time with you you [ __ ]
piece of
I'll take that and I'll take bad and oh
you're standing in the waist
oh whatever caution gate override should
I say I hate that [ __ ] sound voice I
mean Vegas gay bait gay are you [ __ ]
[ __ ]
are you happy now
huh can't move
make what sucks orgasm oh [ __ ] I wish I
could aim down the site understand
Thursday I guess I gotta shoot someone
hope I should Rodriguez there we go
shout that [ __ ]
I said it wasn't Rodriguez take your
gumbo worse
[Music]
you